and you're all happy about look at look
at that smile though look at that smile
you're all happy me my wife and M man
did the prophet say to Omar how are you
talking to my wife bro that's my wife
why you talking to my wife for is now
the prophet wasam because he didn't say
that
to is he
now to your standards at the youth
huh brothers and sisters it is the
winter season in the UK today in my
house my boiler broke and the house was
freezing cold my kids are wearing
jackets I'm trying to find heating and
as a father I'm trying to make sure my
kids my wife are warm imagine the people
around the world I'm working with one om
say 100% donation policy charity who are
helping Syria Lebanon and Afghanistan
people who are freezing to death intense
brothers and sisters donate whatever you
can because today's experience with me
showed me Subhan Allah how vulnerable we
are and just made me remember those
people who are in need whatever you
donate guys even if it is1 help those
people in the most countries asalam Alum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
this is a video that's been long long
overdue where do we start now there's a
message to this guy uh I'm going to call
him a child why am I going to call him a
child like I'm not I'll be honest with
like I don't like to respect anybody I'm
not somebody who's behind the camera and
tries to put a Persona act TR tries to
act hard like I'll be honest with you
whatever I believe I will say it to your
face if I'm going you a child on on here
on camera when I see you I'll call you a
child as well so I want to make this
very clear I'm not trying to act hard
I'm not trying to put in a Persona I
don't like to act fake it just really
irritates me especially after you Adam
yes um you are the foot soldier of
Parris the guy who you know is a
fullblown z support ZM here uh directly
or indirectly you know the foot soldier
you're the one who also um said oh you
know what's going to happen if we
boycott how's it going to change blah
blah blah so we know who you are I've
done a video about you anyways so this
time it's um there's many like you
around there so this is not just
specifically to you but we're going to
react to a video now this video I just
found interesting just popped up my
Instagram alhamdulillah I'm so great
that it popped up you know why cuz just
you you have Islam and you have people
who think how Islam should be so this is
why you need to divorce Muslims certain
Muslims from Islam Islam is free from
them today we're going to react to a
video where this man and many like him
who falsely call people the youth call
men the youth give these labels with
zero zero knowledge zero zero and we're
going to show today from the Quran and
the Sunnah
sahab the prophet Muhammad s Ali
wasallam we're going to go through their
lives and let's see if they are you the
the we claim to be the youth the youth
is somebody who has no problem another
man having intimacy with his sister his
mother his wife his daughter this is a
man who Allah will not look on look at
him
on this is the the the the the
accusation is so severe but here is
let's watch this clip first inshallah
and let's put into perspective inshallah
what is it the youth what falls into the
what is it category you know because you
need to understand just because somebody
can have the traits of the youth does
not mean he is a the okay but let's
watch here we go let's see what this big
she everyone's become a she these days
everyone on social media let's see why
he had to say what he deems to be a
let's see here we go this is a a picture
of um this brother and his wife taking a
picture with mu men cuz they seem as
inspirational they watch his videos
let's watch it for ourself nah bro
imagine the level of the youth you've
got to be to think I've Just Seen muy
M yeah and I'm going to take my wife I
want a picture come on wife come here
wife let's go and take a picture with
another man and you're all happy about
look at SM look at that smile though
look at that smile you're all happy me
my wife and muy
M listen brother our brothers like you
who you know have issues in the man
Department my DMs are open for you guys
you can message me and I'm more than
happy to provide you with some advice
inshallah okay so I'm going to make this
very simple to the point here this is
here he is now questioning the the
protective jealousy of another man he's
there slandering accusing even basically
in directly saying that this man will
enter the fire because he's at the youth
okay and he's now also acting like you
know matal man alhamdulillah Alpha May
wow masah wow oh my gosh you know
talking about the honor of another man
which is a Muslim man and also trying to
dishonor his wife yes okay and at the
same time D indirect the MU M yeah now
I'm going to do something a little bit
simp make you taste your medicine yeah
okay brother Adam I know your honorable
wife your honorable wife is going to be
watching this yes your wife is going to
be watching you're going to be watching
this as well you're probably watching
together or one of you guys are watching
it okay no problem yeah okay now I want
to ask you a simple question you've got
a fake level spoke about thisd Hass
someone that you probably respect yeah
he even spoke about this we are going to
now go through the Quran and Sunnah okay
and I want you I want your honorable
wife to know that he she is is married
to a man who has Fai yeah I'm not going
to drop to your level by dishonoring
another Muslim man no I'm not going to
do that yeah your wife is an honorable
woman she's our sister you are our
brother but you need to put in your
place because you have a fake bro I'll
tell it to your face fake bro I'm
telling you fake it's so fake it doesn't
make you a mad because when we look at
evidences from the sah Muslim and bukari
we look at narrations I want you to
answer those bro I want you to answer
them you're not going to run away
because now we are dealing with Islam
we're not dealing with Adam's opinion of
what is Adam's opinion of what is
brother you are a ignoramus bro you have
shown your ignorant because the fact
that you're talking with such certainty
shows how ignorant you are and let me
teach you a life lesson cuz I'm probably
older than you I don't know maybe yeah
I'm 35 let me tell you something if you
carry on with this arrogant attitude I'm
telling you fear Allah Allah will test
you in such a situation W you will eat
your words one by one so let's get
straight into it before that I just want
to play a quick video of ABD Hassan when
it comes to this issue because he also
talks about it and I really admired for
him to do in this video watch this clip
and we're going to go straight into the
evidences and let's see if what Adam
deems to be a the is the prophet
Muhammad sallu alai wasallam
Omar Abu
Bakr Ali and all the other sahaba the
female and male sahabas do they fall
into being a the
let's see if these women have theah
female had
no let's see bro let's watch this video
off first and come
back who came to her and said cover
up said to the prophet's wife cover up
then he went to the prophet and he said
your wife why she not wearing for the
prophet didn't say why are you talking
to my wife for do you understand there
is a concept of that's been falsely
created story I mentioned when Muhammad
Al and his wife had a conflict one of
his students was the person she
appointed ALB said my wife wants you to
be the judge I'm telling you these guys
you don't have more than them trust me
they read better better than you they
trusted their wives and they trusted
themselves but when Brothers have like a
very promiscuous way of thinking and
they look at women in a nasty way they
think that everyone's sexualizing their
wives so guys you heard that for
yourself yeah alhamdulillah and I look I
agree with in this matter perfectly said
fake bro you have fake and certain men
I'm not going to come and see you cuz I
don't know your heart yeah certain men
because they have a perversion they're
perverted individual okay because they
think of other people's wives Etc in a
certain way they think everybody does
the same it's like a thief if I'm a
thief bro and if I will never lend you
my phone no bro cuz I'm like bro if you
lend me your phone I'll steal it so they
think everybody's lacked them again I'm
making a disclaimer I'm not talking
about Adam because this is it can be a
slander so I'm not saying that he's like
that no no no I feel because I'm very
careful I don't want to back by anybody
the prophet said the one who guarantees
what's between his lips and what's
between his legs I will promise him J
inshallah so I'm going to be very
careful I don't want to fall into
anything I don't want to call it like
name back no nothing I'm not saying our
brother Adam has this traits I'm not
saying that I'm saying there are certain
men who are like this now let's go to
the evidences so let's get into in this
is sunnah.com
sbari 146 the wife of the Prophet
Muhammad used to go to Al manasi a vast
open place near Bak at Medina to answer
the call of nature at night Omar used to
say to the prophet wasallam let your
wives be veiled om is going to the
messenger of Allah and saying oh mess of
Allah let your wives be veiled listen
carefully Adam listen carefully please
yeah but Allah's Apostle did not do
so now according
to's is the Prophet Muhammad
huh what are you trying to say bro now H
if I did not tell you this the message
said there is a man who's telling
another man that his wives should be
wailed before Revelation came and he
said no you will call the prophet Sall
wasallam indirectly if I didn't fear
that you fall into kufur I would not
even mention who it is is the prophet
the youth now answer the question bro
answer it let's carry on he did not do
so one night SA the wife of the Prophet
Muhammad went out at Isha time and she
was a tall lady she was known by her
figure Omar addressed and said I have
recognized you can you imagine another
woman man recognizing your wife bro yes
and said oh
SAA um he said oh oh SAA he said so as
he desired e sorry as he desired eagly
that the uh eag that the verse of alab
the observe the veil by the Muslim woman
may be revealed so Allah revealed the
verse of alab a complete body covering
there is another narration that supports
this now let's go to that one sa Z again
Inari
5237 one sa Z went out at night for some
need and Omar saw her and recognized her
and said to her by Allah oh sa you
cannot hide yourself from us so she
returned to the prophet and mentioned
that to him it's the
same spoke about and said to him while
he was sitting in my dwelling taking his
supper and holding a bone covered with
meat in his hand then the divine
inspiration was revealed to him and then
that was stated over he propham saying
oh woman you have been allowed by Allah
to go out of your Deeds did the prophet
say to Omar how are you talking to my
wife bro how you talking to my wife
that's my wife what are you talking to
my wife for huh is now the prophet
because he didn't say that
to is he
now to stand at the youth huh okay now
you might come and say oh but that's
that's the Believers that's our mothers
yeah okay no problem then if that's the
case why do they still need to teach
behind the veil does your mom teach you
behind the veil bro why was the
prophet's wife still instructed to teach
behind the veil yes we say that was
specifically for the prophet's wives
okay if your wife Adam was a person of
knowledge yeah person of knowledge and
she was teaching cuz men used to come
and learn for the prophet's wives does
that mean now you have no
brother we follow Islam we follow the
Quran and we don't follow your opinions
bro we don't follow opinions let's carry
on inshallah yeah another one yes I want
bro this this evidence I'm bringing
evidence I'm bring my opinion how I feel
la la la I don't we don't the um doesn't
need your fake level bro the um does not
need your fake level let's go to the
next one sah Muslim 1480 okay let's go I
swear by Allah that you have no claim on
us so now this is a very interesting one
she went to Allah's messenger and
mentioned that to him there was a dis
between her and her husband he said
there is no maintainance due to you from
him and he commanded her to spend the in
the house of sharik but when but then
said the prophet is given this Verdict
by the way she she divorced from her
husband okay this is talking about okay
that that is that is a woman whom my
companions visit so the prophet is
saying to
Fatima go to's house to do your period
but then the prophet remembers and says
what that actually said he says actually
no because that is the woman whom my
companions visit regularly so better
spend the period in the house
of the blind man yes for he is a blind
man and you can put off your garments
and when the is over inform me she said
when my period ID was over I mentioned
that to him mu suan etc etc do you know
what im nawi says IM nawi says when the
prophet mentioned this is a companion
who she is a a woman that many of my
companions visit she was known as a
righteous woman who used to serve food
or feed the male
companions is now the prophet allowing
free mixing bro is a free mixing
happening does he not have a what's
going on a what's going on bro IM saying
she was a woman who would have guessed
men coming to eat eat bro eat food eat
food W one tell me please yeah let's go
to the next one sunnah.com
there's another one yes okay I'm
bringing evidences 3798 narrated
by a man came to the Prophet The Prophet
sent a messenger to his wives to bring
something for the man to eat listen
carefully bro this is how beautiful
Islam is Islam is free from these
extreme brothers who have extreme views
okay until it overrides them like the
prophet said do not go to extreme in
your religions because it's going to
overtake you we know many people who
fell off their religion because of this
don't act arrogantly bro the prophet
said sent a messenger to his wife bring
something for the man to eat but they
said they had nothing except water then
Allah's M messenger said who will take
this person a man or enter or entertain
him as a guest so there is a man and
he's asking some of the companions to
take care of him and ansar man said I so
he took him to his wife and said to her
entertain generously the guest of
Allah's messenger she said we have got
nothing except the meals of my children
he said prepare your meal light up your
lamp and let your children sleep if they
ask for supper so she prepared her meal
light lit lit up her lamp and made her
children sleep and then stood stood up
pretending to mend her lamp but she put
it off I'm going to make you guys
understand yeah the both of them
pretended to be eating but they really
went to bed hungry in the morning the
Ansari went to Allah's messenger who
said tonight Allah laughed wondered at
your action then Allah revealed but give
them immigrants preference over them but
th those who give the immigrants
presence over themselves even though
they were in need of that and whoever is
saved from the cadness such are they
will be successful so let me get this
right the pro say there is a guest which
of my companions going to take him to
his house and insain him a man and says
he can come to my house his wife says to
we do not have food to serve him you we
got little food kids food he says put
the kids to bed bring the food to the
guest now something very interesting
happens here the man his wife the
companion and his wife are sitting at
the same table or the floor with the man
serving him food turning off the lamp so
the man doesn't feel bad that they gave
the only food that was there so they and
they pretended to eat when there was
nothing to eat so the guest doesn't feel
embarrassed and then Allah subhana
laughed the way it befits majest to this
the way they went about it just so they
can you know you get what I'm trying to
say not make the man feel guilty that
they eating the only food that's left my
brother is the prophet now this
companion and his wife sitting at the
same table eating with another guy is he
a deth bro if I didn't mention you this
was a companion of Allah and I told you
you say he's a de a man eating food with
a his wife and another man you said this
man is a de you're a j you are a Jah bro
you are a fullblown festar grade A J I'm
sorry I have to be harsh with you you
know why because your attitude is
arrogant bro yes let's go to the next
one I've got two more for you and then
we're done alhamdulillah yeah and I've
got a knockout one for you inshah so
let's go to
something one second okay so this one
this is as ya was a woman from the an
and a companion of the Prophet Muhammad
she was distinguished for her s sagacity
and eloquence indeed she was nicknamed
the orator of all woman but she was also
a woman of learning and she reported the
Prophet The Prophet's Hadith she was
clearly reliable as a reporter okay now
Asma was also keen on Jihad joining
Muslim armies on several occasion she
accompanied the prophet on Expedition
that led to the fall of Mecca to uh to
Islam she also participated in the great
battle of Al against the Byzantine
empire in order to appreciate her
knowledge we may relate the following
Story one day she came to the prophet
Muhammad as he was sitting with the
number of his companions I addressing
him she said messenger of God may my
both my parents be sacrificed for you
this was a traditional phrase of
endearment use mostly figuratively I am
a I am an emissary from woman to you God
has sent you his Messenger to both men
and women we believe in you and your
lord yet we women are restricted home
band we stay in our homes if give your
uh uh give you your pleasure and bear
your children you men have been F
favored over us with attending Friday
prayer congregation prayers in mosque
visiting the sick attending funerals
offering the pilgrimage uh repeatedly
and with that is more than that fighting
for God's cause what a man when a man
goes out intending pilgrimage of jihad
we take care of your property so sew
your clothes and bring up children for
you do we share the reward she's come to
the prophet wasallam a woman who is
married coming to the prophet wasallam
in front of companions are they free
mixing bro what's happening yeah the
prophet turned to His companion asked
him have you ever heard a better
statement by a woman that is the one who
is asking about the battles of her faith
he praised her he did not come and say
where's your ha woman where's your
husband why are you talking to me
there's companions here why you coming
here why you talking to he praised her
yes he praised her they said we could
have not thought that a woman would ever
be able to express such meaning meanings
as this lady the prophet turned to Asma
and said listen woman and inform Other
Woman who have sent you that a woman who
is a goodly wife keeps to please a
husband doing what he likes is equal to
all of that as she left she was
glorifying God yes she was glorifying
God now this is what we're talking about
what Islam is now this is where I'm
going to in slowly slowly wrap up the
wife of Abu Bakr as and Fatima yes now
as you know a brief insight to who Asma
is and her relationship with ban Hashim
okay okay so he was married to three or
four Companions of the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him yes okay Ali married
Asma on one occasion their children
Muhammad IB jaff from my other husband
and and Muhammad IB Abu Bakr each of the
two began boasting of his lineage yes
one was saying I'm the son of you know
Jaffer one say I'm son of ab Bakr my my
father was better than your father Ali
said to Asma Ali is married to her now
it said to Asma pronounce your judgment
regarding this contention hence she said
I have not seen a young star better than
Jaffer nor have I seen a middle-aged man
more virtuous than Abu Bakr and Ali said
you have left nothing for me can you
imagine you are married to your wife
yeah and you're married your wife is
married before and she for example spoke
about this or spoke about you know
this ex-husband of mine was like said
brother brother brother brother are you
now would you come and
say theth she's clearly talking about
her ex-husband and saying he was that he
was giving good qualities of him Etc to
your standard is Ali the youth
now does asma have no to your standard
this is what we are talking about this
is the Crux of the matter look let me
just end on this here I don't want to
Long any further the point I mention is
the following you are a ignoramus if you
can go and point out people and say
nobody I have look and I'm not saying
because of that I've had Brothers their
wives maybe watching out my video and
they might find something beneficial
regarding whatever it is can we take a
picture no problem bro I don't take
pictures with females but no problem
you're in and always I say this as long
as your Maham is there no problem you're
here her husband is here her brother is
there her dad is here and she's there no
problem at all that does not make them a
the you J because according to you all
of these people fall into be the youth
now I'm going to show you what a real
real d looks like in my next video
please guys watch the video I'll be
releasing both of them at once in or
maybe one before that in the video
you're going to see of me reacting to a
fullblown actual de that's what de looks
like that is what a you looks like you
can see that where his daughter is being
chirped moved to by some next man and
he's standing there like a man
when I watched the video I was thinking
I would have bro if this guy was not a
Muslim I would like like I would want to
smash his face bro how are you watching
your wife I mean your your your daughter
getting chur by s next watch that video
I'm going to put a link to in yeah that
is what you call
a not oh some brother his wife wears the
correct hijab Etc doesn't wear make up
they do video together you can't call
him a you J that does not make him a and
I will end on this note guys the final
re Hadith which is let me tell you
something knock out no nobody can say
anything knock out bro knock out yes it
was narrated from Muhammed Abu that his
father SB Abu said Omar Omar asked for
permission to enter upon the message of
Allah and there were some woman of qur
with him who were talking to him and
asking too much him and raising their
voices when Omar asked permission to
enter they got up and hastened to
conceal them themselves the messenger of
Allah sallu alh wasallam gave him
permission to enter so he entered and
the messenger of Allah s wasallam was
smiling Omar said may Allah make you
happy all your life oh messenger of
Allah the messenger of Allah said I
wonder at these women who were with me
when they heard your voice they hastened
to conceal themselves Omar said oh M of
Allah you are more deserving of being
feared then Omar said oh enemies of your
souls do you fear me and do you do not
fear the messenger of Allah they said
yes for you are harsher and tougher than
the messenger of Allah the messeng of
Allah said by the one who my soul is the
Shan never meets you on a road but he
takes a different Road the point is what
guys the point is yes was a bit harsher
but we follow the tradition the Sunnah
of the Prophet Muhammad sallam it is his
Sunnah we follow there might be people
who are harsher and let me tell you
there were people watch abdah Omar's son
forbade his wife to go Juma and when he
told his son that this is against a
Sunnah and he still carried it he
boycotted him now according to abdah
Omar's um um son's level we're going to
call it whatever it is yeah blame where
then are you a bro then you're you're
why send your wife to J yeah are you
yeah if your wife I don't know like you
off with your wife yeah for example if
your wife wears some kind of foundation
Etc going out are you with the youth if
she goes out inside the house catches a
b bus Etc where she goes where men could
be looking at trying to talk to are you
the bro if you let your wife go out to
the shop are you the bro when she go to
univers are you with the youth when she
goes to work are you with the youth when
she whatever are you with the youth are
you with the youth bro because it all
backfires on you doesn't it this is my
reason I'm doing this please don't talk
without knowledge because to your
condition you're going to have to call
the mess of Allah and all of those
people the
youth fake fake that's what it is it's a
fake and I hope this a lesson to you
from myself inshallah till next time
brother and sisters that's all I have to
say may Allah bless and preserve you
share this far and wide for those people
who are absolutely ignorant and protect
your tongue stop labeling people the
youth when you don't even know what it
means till next time